[Música]
hola bienvenidos a 5 minutos con la
violencia se recrudece en mexico así lo
evidencia en las cifras correspondientes
al mes de mayo que indican que el quinto
mes del año 2021 registra la cifra más
alta de homicidios con dos mil 595 casos
es también la cifra más alta desde que
comenzó la administración del presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador esto según
el más reciente reporte de la
organización semáforo del delictivo
precisamente su director santiago roel
desde la ciudad de monterrey en el norte
de méxico está con nosotros para hablar
sobre este informe señor roel gracias
por estar con nosotros y explíquenos
brevemente para la audiencia que está
fuera de las fronteras mexicanas que es
el semáforo delictivo que representan
estos tres colores y qué niveles indican
mira somos una organización ciudadana en
búsqueda de la paz en méxico y lo
hacemos reportamos estas cifras de una
manera sencilla que todo el mundo puede
entenderla el rojo quiere decir que no
está funcionando la estrategia y debe
replantearse por el contrario el verde
quiere decir que vamos bien y hay que
reforzar la estrategia y el amarillo al
amarillo es un punto intermedio en donde
pudiéramos irnos hacia el rojo o hacia
el verde algunas estrategias funcionan
pero otras no
básicamente esos son los colores señor
rosell ustedes en este informe indican
que la estrategia de seguridad del
gobierno ha fallado y entre esas
estrategias está la militarización de la
guardia nacional que era tal vez la
bandera de esta política de seguridad
del gobierno del presidente andrés
manuel lópez obrador que más detalles
tienen ustedes y porque argumentan este
posible fracaso
mira se ha mantenido muy alto el
homicidio en méxico sobre todo el que
nos ocupa que son las ejecuciones de
este mercado negro de drogas en las
narcoejecuciones representan el 80 a
veces el 90 por ciento de los homicidios
en una ciudad o en un estado y esto ha
continuado en el sexenio incluso este
sexenio es el que tiene las cifras más
hacen visto y como lo reportan bueno el
mes pasado fue el peor mes en la
historia de este sexenio entonces esto
debería quedar claro para todos que no
es la estrategia en la militarización y
la forma de resolver esto esta
administración había prometido la
regulación de algunas drogas para
quitarle la plata a estos grupos y con
ello bajar el plomo y es correcto pero
no han hecho absolutamente nada al
respecto por el contrario han tratado de
vender esto de la guardia nacional y lo
más peligroso la militarización de esta
guardia nacional como una solución y no
es así ya hemos visto en estos
casi 30 meses que no no funciona y el
llevarlo a un grado mayor de
militarización sería un grave peligro
para la democracia mexicana una cosa son
las funciones de la policía y otras las
del ejército y en ninguna democracia
moderna están mezcladas o están a cargo
del ejerció señor roel durante las
recientes campañas para las elecciones
parlamentarias y elecciones regionales
allí en mexico
hubo muchos asesinatos de personas que
estaban involucradas en las campañas
asesinatos de muchos de los candidatos
hubo muchas denuncias también de
intimidación que tanto permea el crimen
y entre ese crimen me refiero también a
la mafia ya los diferentes carteles en
la política mexicana según este reporte
que ustedes publican
pues mira ahí hay ciertas regiones en
méxico sobre todo el pacífico porque es
una ruta de trasiego rumbo a eeuu en
donde se manifiesta con más claridad de
donde está sinaloa sonora baja
california michoacán también tiene que
ver con los puertos porque por ahí se
reciben algunas mercancías de china para
y crear otras drogas y mucho de esto
tiene que ver con el control no
solamente del puerto sino también de las
ciudades de los municipios más que del
estado o del país porque porque muchos
de estos grupos buscan el apoyo de la
policía local para la protección de la
mercancía y para la protección del
trasiego esta es la dinámica que se da
entonces definitivamente tratan de
influir en los procesos electorales pues
para obtener esto y si sientes que hay
un candidato que no lo favorece
obviamente el ataque
señores santiago roel rápidamente por
favor los crímenes y los delitos
familiares al interior de las familias
también han aumentado mucho en méxico a
raíz de la pandemia rápidamente como ven
ustedes esta situación rápidamente
tenemos en rojo todos los delitos socio
familiares violación violencia familiar
lesiones y feminicidio en méxico y esto
lleva casi todo el año y se ha
incrementado por el tema de la pandemia
porque son delitos que se dan en casa o
cerca de casa
gracias señor santiago roel director del
semáforo delictivo en méxico a ustedes
muchas gracias por la sintonía
[Música]